algérie
à l' agence nationale pour l'envol au
dessus du soir des batignolles dans la
fraîcheur du petit matin jeanne tient la
main de marque 1 à l' agence nationale
pour l'envol au dessus du square des
batignolles
dans la fraîcheur du petit matin jeanne
tient la main de martin
depuis belle lurette y zont pas de bol à
sont jamais trop fréquenté l'école où
l'on dit pour être en bonne santé
il suffit de bien travailler
depuis le temps qu'ils traînent leur
cavale sont plus trop quoi fréquenter
les bars alors janadi qu'est ce que tu
en penses on pourrait aller à l'agent
agence nationale pour l'envol au dessus
du square des batignolles
dans la fraîcheur du petit matin charles
tient la main de martin
à l' agence nationale pendant vol au
dessus du soir et batignolles dans la
fraîcheur du petit matin jeanne tient la
main de martin
rendez vous est donné dès lors en à
cette heure-ci la ville dort encore
l'agent lisons même sur le toit ce qui
lui chante
il n'y a pas beaucoup de pousser du il
suffit simplement d'être sûr d'en avoir
assez de cette vie qui va de rien de
rien quelques uns à la jasse nationale
blanc balle au dessus du square des
batignolles dans la fraîcheur du petit
matin jeanne tient la main de martin
agence nationale
au dessus du square des batignolles
dans la fraîcheur du petit matin jeanne
mien la main de matin
au dessus les toits c'est rigolo on voit
tout paris on trouve ça beau martin
s'aperçoit que jeanne à froid il la sert
très fort dans ses bras
l'agent avec son briquet nord et
brûlent leurs papiers d'identité
bientôt il ne restera plus rien et déjà
le nez de ma part
nationale pour les vols au dessus du
square des batignolles
dans la fraîcheur du petit matin jeanne
tient la main de martin
palaja nationale blanc tard au dessus du
square des batignolles
ils ne se sont pas lâchés la main quand
on saute et
janet martin
voilà bonjour